joining me right now is the chief
creative officer of epic games
donald mustard uh donald it is great to
have you on the show it's a yearly
tradition
new fortnight season what can you tell
us
oh man so awesome to be here so awesome
to see you
this is amazing jeff you did this yet
again uh
uh so yeah i was so excited right now uh
new season has started we just
all battled galactus together with our
favorite marvel heroes and
and what that's done is it's left the
fortnite zero point exposed and agent
jones is
looking for all these hunters throughout
all these different realities that can
uh help him stop anyone from escaping
from fortnite and
uh we've already seen several characters
come in and we have one more
that he's bringing in right now
[Music]
master chief comes to fortnite you're
getting them all donald
isn't that crazy like master chief is
just one of my
most favorite characters ever in
anything and i'm just we're
so thrilled that he can join the ever
growing cast of characters in
in fortnite uh and the coolest thing is
he's going to be available tonight
uh in fortnite you can go and and get
master chief
and i know there's some more halo coming
as well i heard
yeah so i think uh you know we didn't
want to stop right there and so there's
something else i think we should uh we
should check out
well hello sir it's an honor
hey sarge did you hear oh i guess you
already got the news
what news master chief is coming to
fortnight report what now
it's only one of the most popular video
games in the world
but more obviously it's where we are
right now wait a minute if you had no
idea that we're in fortnite then why do
you have a cardboard cut out of master
chief
perfectly regular reasons whoa
you guys knew around here no the chief
got eliminated by a sneaky blue
that's no blue that's that's ninja
it's such an honor i'm a huge fan of
yours on twitch twitch
is he twitching cause he's blue stop
making us look bad in front of ninja
we're sergeant griff from the popular
web series red versus blue
you probably watched it about 10 years
ago what are you doing here
well it's more than just the chief
coming to fortnite this map is too
it'll be in creative mode starting at 10
a.m eastern time tomorrow
oh so that's what we're doing in
ragnarok you mean basin
i'm pretty sure it was called something
else either way
you can start reliving your favorite
halo memories here in fortnite and maybe
add your own personal touches to the mat
hey wait does that mean we can have
dance battles
come on ninja what do you say uh
save it for new year's
red versus blue donald
[Applause]
yeah isn't that so awesome and so funny
um
so what's awesome about that is that uh
blood gulch was recreated in fortnite
creative
by this awesome creative team that call
themselves atlas creative
and tomorrow at 10 a.m eastern
you'll be able to go into fortnite and
you can play capture the flag in a
recreated version
of blood gulch oh my god it's gonna be
fun everything
is in fortnite right now so are you done
for the season
you know i mean agent jones is uh is
actually just kind of getting
warmed up so uh i think there's actually
one more thing that we should show you
[Music]
thanks doll i have no idea where we're
going next but i'm on board
thanks jeff all right uh donald mustard
from epic games all right come